my dad would always say you know people
who say how did you know you wanted to
be a director he's a director you know
and he would say well you decide you're
a director and you'd be like what it's
not that easy and he said yeah but he
would always say that he was like Popeye
doesn't walk around saying I'm gonna be
Popeye
he's [ __ ] Popeye and I was like yeah
even though that sounds so dumb it's so
true
I love simple [ __ ] like that Popeyes
Popeye dude um by the way he's on me for
the calamari story I told ya last week
he was like I know you don't have guests
on your podcast but I want to [ __ ]
call in um maybe I should call him right
now I wonder if he'll pick up let me see
if I'll pick up bill D'Elia let's do it
here let me make sure that even they've
been but he's not doing anything
I'm calling my dad what are you doing
yo you want to want to I'm um I'm on my
podcast you wanna talk about your
calamari thing here I'll put you on
speaker
right state your [ __ ] claim okay so
my claim is you can't slam a guy for the
way he eats calamari first of all you're
wrong you're wrong
go ahead incorrect okay because because
because first of all you your claim is
that somebody eats
calamari should know how they like to
eat calamari should know that they like
to eat it with
and that's [ __ ] no but you can like
to eat calamari with sauce and without
sauce yeah I know but each calamari you
eat you should know how much sauce you
want it for that calamari no your each
one you eat if you like it with sauce or
without sauce you should be able to
decide okay or not I like that's crazy
dude consistency in the way you eat
something but but but it if you have
listened if you have uh okay so here's
what happened you had the [ __ ]
calamari
oh you had to Calamari's on the thing
you poked one good good through and then
you poked another one and it was
dangling off okay and I and I knew it
was gonna fall off in the sauce and you
[ __ ] it fell off in the sauce and
then you ate the one with half the sauce
on it and then you just dip your fork
and got the other one put it in the fit
in your mouth and you like both of those
the same amount of ways yes
no you're lying okay so then you don't
care you don't allow for the for the
fact that someone okay
okay so if you were gonna order calamari
alright if you were gonna order [ __ ]
alright so okay okay okay so if you were
gonna order calamari and they said okay
but just so you know we ran out of sauce
you'd still get two calamari yes okay
what if they said okay just so you know
just so you know we got two calamari but
we we dropped them all in the sauce and
everywhere and we just basically have a
a plate of calamari but it's all got
sauce all over it you'd you'd say yes to
that - so you like one way better it was
all in sauce okay so so you're saying
that because you dropped it in the sauce
it doesn't matter that much but you
still like it that way and it and yeah
see that's the kind of thing where I
just it's like if a guy like that you
can trust less than a guy who knows how
he likes his calamari that's what I'm
saying so you're saying that you like me
less no I don't like you less but it's
like you're the guy in the movie that
like double-crosses someone but no you
aren't that guy but if you were in a
book if your character was in a book and
like they were like and he was eating
calamari and one dropped off in the
sauce and he still ate it just like he
ate the one without the sauce you and
then that guy went on page like 600 700
and he like [ __ ] took the the the the
hero of the of the story for a ride and
was like a dick about it
you'd be like oh okay I get it the
foreshadowing was the [ __ ] calamari
eating there's no [ __ ] apology dude
you're the guy I told you this but
you're the guy who gets the [ __ ]
truck with the flatbed and they think
it's the top over it because he doesn't
know how he wants his [ __ ] truck yeah
I get that all right I love you and
that's where I kiss you on the face
every [ __ ] time it's in my eyes
it's in my eye about whatever it's too
high mom knows but it's on your cheek
whatever man you know where you want to
kiss [ __ ] and that's the ID you
should know how to have your calamari
all right in the morning alright I'll
talk to you later love you it's the
wrong number alright you guys there you
have it you wanted to call it in status
claim and that's what's up with the
calamari [ __ ] and that's it dude we're
done we'll end on that